like what you've been doing chan i do
work out but not as much as you guys
would think dude your legs look strong
you could be really muscular easily oh
you're [ __ ] so crazy
why are you not working out you could be
your body would change so quick it'd be
sick i'm looking out right oh you are
taking it easy
yeah
no you do and you didn't get any of that
recorded well we just gave you
ryan just ryan just brian just gave you
one of the biggest comments but he does
look at this look at the whole time he
changes so quickly you could be a
[ __ ] monster you totally could i get
a little bit of a veins when i started
yeah dude you're korean
i am
korean of [ __ ]
all right all right yeah here we go
what's up guys brendan has to be brandon
has to be home he's got a leak
he had something going on in his house
and he's [ __ ] he's like he he
literally couldn't get out of the house
so i'm here you're here i'm here we're
here to do this [ __ ] hey together
together again
again i know we're division oh yeah yeah
we could get ah
good that feels dude you uh you heard a
conversation between my my mother and i
about my dad that's hey that's a
parental conversation my dad had kidney
stones in his bladder this is what
happens whenever 81 sharp stones they
don't pass
them out you got it no you can't they're
too big so they got a black they got to
get up the in your dick hole they go oh
they do oh yeah and they they laser the
[ __ ] out of them
okay they they pulverize they know you
up
you're on you're in general anesthesia
you're out oh they knock you out for
this yeah okay
that was a 20 minute 30 minute operation
then he comes too and the guy wants to
go walking yeah oh
he wants to walk the next day that's
just my mother my mother is like you're
going to have a heart attack because
you're 8 000 feet above sea level and
there's ice on the ground
and then they have a huge argument and
then i get caught in the middle of it
yeah
now my dad
tipped out at two five five two hundred
fifty-five hundred fifty-five six four
two fifty-five no no wait wait wait
because according to brendan
oh now he's no because he doesn't have
enough muscle but but all that weight's
in his tummy it is a big guy
i heard he said he eats bananas like
crazy he'll eat all the food why
he'll eat all the food he don't care you
put out if you put out 10 cookies he's
eating 10. you put out one cookie he's
eating one you put out all the cookies
and a tub of dough yeah it's gone by the
end of the day no you're not like that
daddy's has he has he always been like
that
my dad's always been that way i'm
different see how did you yeah where did
you find your
i thought you have i don't know
i think there's a genetic
thing that some people have which is
they are they're naturally moderate
i'm naturally a moderate
person a consumer yeah in moderation of
everything
i'm the only person that could do the
best blow on the planet and do one line
and be like i'm done you know just like
you're like yeah people i never had a
thing i never get drunk never been a
drug guy oh yeah i've never seen you
drunk ever
nobody you know you you do the the sip
and go but it's not because i'm
disciplined it's because my my chemistry
my body is way more delicate than most
people i'm a you're very cautious of
your body i'm just i'm just i just i
break down too quickly for me it's like
oh i can't take this yeah see i'm not
that way either you know me i'm not
reckless at all no you're you and i are
pretty moderate yeah yeah i i just kind
of but it also comes down to what you
like so what what i like is stand up
what i like is writing what i like is
my my interests are very like boxing i'm
always trying to box you i love boxing i
love those things that i like learning a
language that's difficult so
but
the thrill seeking getting drunk getting
in groups shouting and going crazy
raging not my thing when we would go out
i never wanted to fight i just all i
want to do with my friends is laugh and
pick up girls yeah
that was fun but i mean see i was
different i was just so quiet
i just kind of stood in the corner any
time i would go to parties
yeah yeah that's fair i mean part of
that feels like maybe you just didn't
know where you fit in yeah right yeah
i've always felt like a just like kind
of like a lone wolf yeah you know what i
mean like a kind of person just kind of
just steps aside and you know granted
like yeah like in in the worlds that i'm
in like you know the the whole punk rock
skateboarding and comedy like it it is
pretty like what say something you got
something to say man look i'm sick of
both of you no no no no no no you laugh
at my four thousand dollar guitar
collection
you left somebody and i know who's the
older who's famous who who sent me a
clip of you singing
i'll tell you later he goes he goes i
don't understand this
what do you mean he goes well he's super
intelligent but i don't understand why
he's doing this kind of music because i
don't understand this music i go it's
energy it's a subculture of energy
that's all it is hey
yeah you understand of course i do bubba
listen how did you catch that
chappelle i was
i was
going to punk rock concerts and
listening to punk rock
when you were not born i was born 87.
we're exactly 20 years apart yeah so i
was very aware of that stuff literally
before you were born uh-huh that's a
little bit my generation i mean it's
kind of dumb that you understand that
yeah i wonder who this famous person is
well because i couldn't figure out what
what was going on with it i was like
this is just noise like it just
yeah but it's it's a subculture of
energy it's an energy it just feels good
it's also like always defiant abstract
yeah
it's it's anti-music in a way yeah yeah
i don't like i really like doing it
so would you what do you think well
you're you're you're it's it's an
expression of sort of rage and chaos
yeah that's fine and it's just all this
built up like
it's probably a form of uh it's probably
a way of people who participate in that
subculture of
regulating their energy you regulate yes
right you regulate your
you know like what i think we don't
realize is that we're always
trying in one way or another
to stay sane
yes we're always in one way or another
trying not to kill each other or
ourselves
albert camus there are a lot of
philosophers
who was the great french existentialist
he wrote the book eternity the stranger
okay and and uh he said um the
fundamental question
when when a human being kind of matures
into a fully realized person
the the question the fundamental problem
of
the human condition is
why shouldn't i kill myself
yeah in other words
you know you're faced with this thing
you can choose to decide that the that
the universe is meaningless and that
you're just an iraq or you can choose to
believe that the universe is has a great
deal it has a lot of stuff
and i believe in the latter i'm not i
don't i'm not a nihilist no no well
cause like most of the people like in
that that genre that i'm in like yes it
all looks like aggressive but most of
those people
are pretty positive people
you know what i mean like i mean
i mean when you're in your youth yeah
but you know the younger younger you
know you kind of have like this angst or
whatever but like as you're when you're
older and you're like you still
appreciate the music for what it is like
it honestly it has like shifted you well
because you're like a positive person
yeah but that also the other thing about
punk rock or anything expression like
that
is for a second for a little while for a
couple of hours you're putting you're
you're putting on a costume and a mask
like that so so
well
like what you're doing probably is
you and the people moshing and listening
to it in a way
are
are just taking a little time out of
their week
put on a mask of insanity to just kind
of act out
to act out to in a controlled way yeah
just to flip out in a ritualistic manner
it's no different than dancing around a
fire and and chanting incantations yeah
yeah it's no different than so many
things that that allow you to kind of
primarily scream
and and just to like let it out it's
like yes let me have it let me have a
second to do this and then boom
yeah when you're young and maybe to an
extent when you're older but when you're
young especially like you go through a
lot of [ __ ]
periods of your life where you're trying
on different
personas yeah you don't have your
persona yet so you try things you try to
be brooding you try to be the comic you
try to be the magician you got to be the
warrior you i tried to be the warrior
for a long time i i just did i was you
were always the funny guy yeah but i was
ashamed of that yes
but i didn't unders because nobody
nobody taught me the inherent value of
it nobody who taught me the inherent
value of being vulnerable emotional
nobody taught me the inherent value of
being imaginative artistic scientific
with all like all the like places you've
lived before and all the cultures like
different cultures you've i come from a
very different generation of men
where masculine and feminine were very
strongly defined you understand no
that's fair yeah yeah so so so i wasn't
taught
i i should have been taught hey brian
you're a man you're not the kind of man
that
jackal willing is
okay he he's a navy seal built and
that's what you wanted yeah he's built
to bear down he's built to impose his
will he's a born enforcer he's a warrior
he's a spartan you think people are born
with that like the giant
mentality
tim kennedy's yes uh you know i mean the
list goes on like the david goggins and
stuff like that like well
yes because i think some men
are
some men
we all we all i'm talking about men here
but is it like men i'm talking there are
archetypes that you fill their psychic
structures you're born with probably
that we all fill a role a lot of like
like the upanishads people talk about
this like the ideas
there there are there are artists
some people are born artists other
people are born warriors yeah other
people are born merchants they their
their mind my friend is worth a billion
250 million dollars and i said
how do you do that
he said what do you mean like
what is what does that question mean
like
so my buddy david he's my new year he's
a really good guy okay and he's like
he's 52 and he's got whatever you think
is a lot of money he's got more he's got
crazy money right
but david david said
like i looked at him and i go what is it
how do you account for your success
because he's he's started he goes from
one business to the other he starts at
business it becomes huge he starts
another business becomes huge there are
people like that right he's super good
at the game of capitalism and he's an
amazing entrepreneur okay all right and
i said how do you do it and he said
did you ever watch the queen's gambit
and i said yeah you know how she dreams
of
chess moves he said i do that with
business so when i saw that movie i went
oh [ __ ] i do that with business so he
goes to bed and he comes up with
that's what you he he was born he was
born with well he's also a guy he's he
was born with a couple things one i
think is people like that are born with
that ability right they have
they see
they see things you you and i don't see
in terms of on in a marketplace what's
needed what can be done better uh
what that kind of stuff right yeah but
then they also probably have the type of
temperament also where they're very
competitive
uh they're they're kind of fearless
you know they're um they have an ability
to focus
like crazy until the job is done okay
you know what i'm saying yeah
and and then of course they probably
came from a good family structure that
taught them certain things he comes
probably from a tradition where
that supported that kind of
entrepreneurial spirit some cultures
support that yeah okay so so if you're
lebanese if you're syrian if you're
nigerian if you're iranian if you're
jewish a lot of times you're gonna come
from a culture that is supportive of
that of that that that defines
masculinity along those parts
yeah
so he uh longer more i guess more would
that be more of a traditional
yeah
you know cultures tend to hold certain
like if you're if you're ethnically han
chinese
or you're korean you're getting an
education [ __ ] and chances are
you're gonna get really good at a
musical instrument and probably even a
sport
you know like it's so funny you say that
because yeah i was talking to a buddy
recently
uh a guy a guy i just had met uh and his
family came over from uh uruguay yeah
and his father was a doctor out there
right they came up from uruguay moved to
new york
right and
he he was like you're going to college
you're doing all these things and
eventually he dropped out of college
yeah and his father he said his father
was so
upset because they're like it means like
subject to them it's like means you
can't what are you gonna say like he was
like
i [ __ ] came from
like i brought all of us yeah my whole
uh this whole family from uruguay yeah
to to new york right
now i got to tell my people that that
yeah yeah i couldn't it was i couldn't
even raise my son and bring him through
college because somewhere because you
blame yourself yeah and granted granted
he
my buddy still turned out super super
super [ __ ] right successful it's just
not not to his but so but but see that's
why you know what i mean yes and that's
why in my opinion sometimes your parents
can constrict you because
again if you are following your inner
drive your inner your primal drive
you are a certain thing right you're a
certain thing
you you are going to be uh somebody who
brendan is a guy who loves business
he loves he can just see where money is
to be made he's very turned on by that
it's how he thinks yeah
because he's but it's creative it's a
way of him being creative sports were
great for him because he was built that
way but sports are secondary in his mind
like he's probably a born creative in
his own way okay not probably he is
so you know
we all i really believe that we get into
trouble as people when we don't follow
that
impulse i wonder why that's not a thing
like
in america where it's like where like
school like you know
it's hard because it's really hard you
know what i mean you know what yeah i'll
tell you why because when you're young
you have to be exposed to range you have
to be exposed to everything right so
your education has to be you have to be
exposed to everything so you can maybe
find what it is you want sometimes you
don't know enough about the world you
know it exists see when i think about me
with school like
i was [ __ ] you know i just it was so
hard for me to care about school because
of what was going on at home
so i just never [ __ ] cared you know i
mean granted i probably i probably could
have done something with it yeah but
you're you know you were in chaos but
yeah it was too much in chaos to even
like care when i think about all those
times like getting into trouble with
teachers and acting out and every time
they would kick me on stuff like that
obviously they had every right to do so
you know but meanwhile they didn't know
yeah but what was going on what happened
you know
you started doing stand-up and what
happened was yeah it put you in order
because what what that means is that
stand-up for you makes sense you felt it
and you go oh yeah this is right yeah
this makes me feel good and it makes
other people feel good this gives me
this is adventure but it also gives me
some certainty well it's made me learn
about myself
it's like forced me to like
you know two things that have like
really forced me well there's quite a
few things but like some of the stronger
things that have made me like really
take the time to just understand
me as a person
you know
losing my brother
um getting in the stand up
and quitting uh drinking those are the
things that have like forced me to go
hey learn something about you
you know those are really strong
interesting things you just said yeah
those are [ __ ] milestones losing your
brother
deciding to do stand-up yeah bro i was
thinking about this george wallace was
talking about what a small fraternity
george wallace yeah like what a small
fraternity you know how rare it is to be
a comic and especially a comic that can
do what you do yeah like i've talked to
rogan about this a lot like how many
people can actually be this good not to
be you know like [ __ ] you
come on he's tough yeah i was watching
like
some of the best shows of my life at 55
this weekend in miami like this saturday
late show
i'm just standing ovation i'm not
bringing this up for me but i'm saying i
thought to myself
i saw this in my mind's eye
like i always feel so right and so where
i'm supposed to be when i'm on stage
yeah so once i found and accepted that i
wasn't a warrior
and that i was i was a magician yeah i
was a i was a i was a i was did i hurt
your heart no i was a comic and somebody
said your masculinity comes from your
comedy dude stop trying to be this war
you're not tim kennedy yeah you know i
i'm not even physically
built
to deal with the cold i wouldn't last
tim is a guy who can [ __ ] deal with
the cold
and deal with lack of sleep and carry
200 pounds on his back
i i'm a pretty athletic guy for a
[ __ ] but that means i'm an athletic
guy like a dancer is yeah i'm not a
[ __ ] i'm a cat not a bull
you know and so
even my physicality would betray me like
your body
and your mind are like dude
like
oh do you know why i would never be a
great athlete why yes i physically even
if i had the physicality
the reason i wouldn't be a great athlete
is i overthink [ __ ] i'm a head case i'm
a [ __ ]
if the pressure came on
i would psych myself out i would choke
if i was a tennis player i'd be like
don't miss a serve don't miss a serve
that's because i have an imagination oh
it's my brain your brain's like i'm
crazy yes but i better be crazy if i'm
gonna be a comic and surprise the [ __ ]
out of audiences yeah over and over
again with somehow i keep finding ways
to do yeah i need to be a crazy
[ __ ] yeah that is interesting
like well like your perspective in the
way like you think of it like i do it
like i i hold on to stand-up comedy
so much because it's like i don't know i
feel like every day i'm just learning
something about myself and one thing
i've like learned is like
you know i'm like oh no one can ever
define you no one ever could like no
matter what anyone says yeah about you
no one can ever [ __ ] define you and
if they do oh well as long as you know
who the [ __ ] you are
you know what i mean then
then what anyone else says does not
matter might even be that's what i
[ __ ] learned and so like it makes me
think of comedy in this in this fun dope
way and it's like oh i could talk about
real [ __ ] i could talk about my life i
could talk about [ __ ] oh yeah abusive
stuff i can talk about my dad being in
prison for 17 years
[ __ ] why why can't i correct you know
because i'm able to define it because
it's my life that's right that's that's
how i like think of it you know that's
the way to do it i mean that's the whole
point yeah what's cool about writing and
stand up and all that [ __ ] is that you
start to uh get a real sense
of the questions that you are
preoccupied with yeah you get a sense of
the questions you're trying to answer
and you've got to stand you get a sense
of what you actually
honestly revere
and what you honestly fear yeah and what
you at the core of your being want to be
versus who you are pretending to be
mm-hmm right so that's kind of why when
did it what did it shift for you this
[ __ ] uh i don't want to be this
[ __ ] warrior anymore or like i'm or
just understanding i'm not just [ __ ]
sure
realizing i didn't want to be an actor i
didn't like the process i mean realizing
that um
just like taking inventory but i'm such
a late starter dude
my my biggest flaw
what do you mean lately sorry in
entertainment
no in my own brain
my biggest flaw the other good thing is
learning what you're the worst at and
i'm i'm my biggest flaws i was very
optimistic about the world i i suffer
from something called wishful thinking
and the universe is all bliss and loves
me
no it doesn't
the fundamental difference between the
people i know that are super successful
like rogan and me
is that rogan always looked at the world
as a very dangerous place and looked at
the cost of certain
like of not being buttoned down and he
was able to move
of being late
of not being very honest and direct with
what you want yeah of not setting goals
and going for them
regardless of friendship or anything no
you know like like i gotta get this done
i gotta get my job done being
disciplined was that he was very aware
that if you don't do that
you the result might be the worst
possible outcome you can imagine for me
i never entertained the idea that
anything bad could happen at all
and the truth is when you behave that
way you're still a child in a way you're
still being a boy you're still being
naive
right yeah yeah so what i would have
said is i would i would have if i would
go back to my life and say brian you're
21 i'd say
first of all shut the [ __ ] up and listen
more that's fine
number two i didn't have any problem
with discipline and accomplishment i i
would set my i i'm disciplined i'm
accomplished this is another one
never be late never be late number three
there is a very bad side to a lot of
people and a good side beware of their
bad side yeah not everybody is as nice
not everybody looks at the world like
bunny rabbits and [ __ ] roses like you
do you naive little [ __ ]
but i was
because
jesus is right it's not because it's not
because i'm not i don't know
i'm a better person
it's a it's not it's because some
people's lives
are bad and it turns them bad or it
turns them selfish or it turns them
[ __ ] dangerous oh i can only [ __ ]
imagine if i didn't get help with my
[ __ ] anger
oh my god i could only [ __ ] imagine
there you go the type of person i
wouldn't be here i wouldn't be sitting
next to you and there's no way in
[ __ ] hell right and
the fourth thing i would have said is
and i was pretty good at this but the
fourth thing i've said is
you better
you better
follow through and get super serious
about everything and put that stuff
ahead of trying to make everybody happy
and trying to get everybody to like you
which my my biggest problem
my biggest problem is i wanted everybody
to like me
no matter
i wanted all the girls to like me yeah i
wanted all the guys to like me and i
would do and say whatever it was just to
be the guy who walked in the room and
everybody smiled at okay yeah that's
called that's [ __ ] wild that's a
that's like that's low self-esteem you
wanted to and did you assume like
everyone liked you
they did like me yeah i never had a
problem getting like dove davidoff said
that was that was completely opposite my
friends would always say even the
biggest [ __ ] in the room like you
that's not a problem
i was good at making people yeah because
i like them
i like people yeah and i was out of that
no but there is
no like oh like no i'm saying there's
nothing wrong with liking people you
ever hear the expression i think jesus
said it um never cast pearls before
swine i didn't read the bible yeah but
you know what that means don't cast
pearls before swine
don't cast beautiful things in front of
pigs
like
pearls pearls are beautiful they're a
gem
don't don't don't present them to a pig
a pig doesn't know what to do with yeah
yeah okay okay
only reserve your reserve
so this is right
before
swine means to offer something very
valuable someone who is unable to
appreciate that value yeah most often
the phrase is rendered as the admonition
don't cast your pearls before swine
meaning don't offer what you hold dear
to someone who won't appreciate it
that's all i did my whole life yeah
and all i wanted was everybody to like
me and once i got my closest people to
like me my friends but especially my
family i was like i got you already let
me go make this stranger like me
okay because it made me feel safe
because it made me feel wanted because
it made me feel special
or whatever it was who cares what the
psychology was who gives a [ __ ] but it
was bad see i had a chip on my shoulder
i just assumed everyone i just assumed
that everyone was [ __ ] against that
has to tell you now because it's like
hey i'll i'll [ __ ] kill you
that's on traffic yeah but that's how i
was like i just assumed people were like
out to [ __ ] get me
you know
and i mean obviously you [ __ ] know
where it stems from but yeah that's how
i i never thought that like i want
everybody like me you know i like i
didn't give a [ __ ] you liked me i
assumed that you didn't and i was just
like ready for you it's good you know
that's just how i look what look how you
grew up but but that's not i mean i
don't think that's like the warrior
thing i don't know like where i stand
that was you're an artist like
what you're an artist who who was who
was put in a very dangerous situation
where you have trouble breathing mm-hmm
i mean come on
and i i i was that way to an extent only
because of the way my a little bit of
the chaos you know that i grew up with
but
that was i just wanted order and i
wanted i wanted routine i never had to
order a routine what it wouldn't like
did you look at something to go like hey
this is like [ __ ] i don't know gi joe
or something and just go yeah i want to
be that [ __ ] warrior my dad was a
huge marine and a very big okay oh i
forget that yeah yeah he was the kind of
guy that he was a man's man and it was
effortless for him he didn't notice the
cold he's straight he's straight
he didn't notice the cold he didn't know
i remember he wouldn't even notice what
what he was he couldn't he wouldn't even
taste the food he was just like
he didn't notice those things he could
wear a [ __ ] he could you could throw
a wool
a coarse wool rope around this [ __ ]
dick and he'd be like i can't notice it
yeah he's just a big
strong [ __ ] face though loud
aggressive dude he he was yeah he was
successful too like he was
he was just like his shoes were size 14
and they were leather and they smelled
smelled like english leather
everything about him he had that
you know if he smoked a pipe it was like
he smelled like tobacco nettle
yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah and i
could never understand how this [ __ ]
guy was so big and also just he was
taller than everybody he was also bigger
and he's also not afraid was he six four
right yeah but he was six four but like
just a natural bone like his elbows like
a josh um
you know like a josh uh barnett barnett
like
that was just a big
when you look at him around other people
and you go like even if he's not six six
he's six four yeah but he's got a size
14 shoe that's much wider than he's got
to get special shoes a huge head you
know just this strong like slow strong
like a like a frankenstein that's just
how he [ __ ] just yeah that was just
him
yeah
yeah yeah so but also his voice would
carry he was an overwhelming presence
yeah a lot of charisma
knew a lot
you know um and so i think when you're a
boy and you're very different than that
right when your father's a giant like a
lion or something like in your mind he
physically represents
uh a lion or physically represents a
bear and you're
a you're you're more of a just uh like a
[ __ ] you're like the kind of cat that
slinks around
at night because there's too many too
many [ __ ] things packs of dogs yeah i
don't know i don't know how to explain
it i this is such a weird thing to say
but even as a boy
i was a natural vegetarian when i would
smell meat being cooked
you ran away i just was like man i don't
know i don't like that smell really yeah
you hate on me when i don't [ __ ] eat
meat
you know even my meat now has to be
grass-fed i'm uh
my clothing has to be soft yeah
i'm just more sensitive and i was
ashamed of being sensitive i was ashamed
of
something that was [ __ ] never learned
or it's hard yeah but so so i'm glad i'm
glad we're talking about this so that
young people can realize that there's no
right way you got to find out who the
[ __ ] are you yeah who the [ __ ] are you
you may not be creative either you might
be somebody who's better at facilitating
and helping creatives you might be a
natural warrior you might like some kids
oh i noticed it when i coached uh cheers
like there were some kids like i know
it's cheerleading or whatever most
people don't know about it but
you i mean when i would coach it like i
could just tell
by the way a kid would walk
walk in walk into practice i go oh
they're
you could just tell yes and then and
obviously those kids ended up like not
succeeding at it at all you know and
eventually i was just like i hoped i
just i'm like i just hope they find
their way it's like you look at it like
i don't like uh
you've done like what judo wrestling and
stuff like that i'm pretty sure you've
been around guys where you could where
they just walk in and you can [ __ ]
tell i taught taekwondo yeah so yeah i i
could look at you i'd be like sorry
taekwondo i said judo this guy's got a
guy he's got no flexibility and no power
that's what i'm saying yeah like if you
were a mathematician you were going to
be too tight if you were a like a a
artist who painted if you were a painter
yeah uh like if you were a fine artist
you were going to be super loose with no
power you could kick it and i could just
take it that makes a lot of fun yeah the
mixture if you're a lawyer
you might be able to knock me the [ __ ]
out it might be yeah that mindset that
middle of the road is that sort of thing
that we have artistic and math together
and some people you just don't want to
[ __ ] with yeah if you had a bad
childhood you're probably going to kick
through my body yeah
that was me
i was watching i was watching four kings
yeah hearns hagler four kings hearns
hagler duran leonard what is it a
documentary about marvelous marvin
hagler
roberto duran
sugar ray leonard
and tommy hearns tommy the hitman hearns
and they were the four great boxers of
their era is this new and and it's
amazing and all those [ __ ]
right there every one of those
[ __ ] came from less than
nothing
less than nothing
less
and some people get destroyed by it and
other people go i'm gonna punch my way
out of this
right it all depends like you're so some
kids do really well with discipline and
order in a household they do super well
with like discipline and they do really
well with a routine like you're waking
up this time and they can fall into that
with no problem right yeah those are the
kids usually that do really well in the
military law enforcement things like
that
artists tend to not do well that [ __ ]
them up they you'll develop resentment
in them and they will run from that [ __ ]
and you'll lose them
so you know you gotta that's the other
thing about having kids you gotta see
what they're natural
what is their natural proclivity what do
they
you know how do they do best by the way
i love the [ __ ] world of boxing i
know like to some people it's like a
dying
breed but i love i still like love like
how those guys were the best especially
and then the guy who probably i mean
they were all amazing but duran man
when i watched that fight of uh wilder
fury three or whatever
i really loved that [ __ ] fight you
see how he just you see how he just
punched
that so he's he's doing this so they'll
teach you like will you look at it
there's space between look look chabel
no space between my chin and my shoulder
yeah you almost knocked me out the other
day
look look no
that's what they see that
like that just
now his hands down here because he's the
distance he's fine but
we're here hey you're pretty [ __ ]
quick cause i tried to swing at you
don't ever forget that i tried hey i
tried to [ __ ] swing it in front of it
i got fast switch master [ __ ] it i did
my genome
i did i was like how the [ __ ] you do
that and he countered
yeah he [ __ ] countered i'm slow slow
so i tried to test you with my you know
just off based off of my you know my
body
chin i got boxing why does my this
lighting makes me so depressed can we
get back we changed it yeah you did
change it yeah you already [ __ ]
hey i need hey this is an announcement
to anybody listening i need a good
videographer and an editor and i'm
hiring
i need somebody who can shoot
and why would you just i'm doing i'm
doing a bunch of [ __ ] for different
brands i'm i'm i have sort of oh god
you're coming up with ways to market
funny you can find any funny assets
yeah there's so many of those [ __ ]
cats out here but i need somebody i can
really work with i need somebody who can
really even even somebody who
understands filmmaking and direction i
need a good editor and i need a really
good videographer so just dm you on your
yes
dm or or um or email me at brian
gmail.com can i ask you something
what
do you want to keep that in there yeah
your email
i i give it i've given it a bunch okay
why will people hit me up yeah i i'd
rather just keep your if i were you i'd
just keep your ig in there no just keep
my email [ __ ] it okay i mean he could
create a [ __ ] second one hit me with
brian gmail.com look at the end of the
day you got to get your nutrition in you
have to and i don't have time i really
truly don't have time to eat all the
fruits and vegetables
well you need because here's the thing
you want you want your vitamins you want
your minerals you want your whole
food-sourced ingredients you want a
multivitamin you want a multi-mineral
you want a probiotic you want you want
you want your greens you want to get all
the minerals you can you want you know
uh and you want it to be bio-available
so how do you get that your body you
want to be able to absorb it yeah okay
athletic greens that's how you get it
ag-1 okay it fills in nutritional gaps
in your diet it supports energy focus
aids with your gut health and digestion
and supports a healthy immune system my
i do a podcast my buddy sam takes this
every morning when i tell you
what people think he's on
he's got so much energy it's crazy
that's what sold me on it and i got too
many people who are high functioning who
use athletic greens so i'm all over this
um and it does it's lifestyle friendly
it doesn't matter if you're keto or
paleo vegan dairy-free gluten-free it
contains less than one for everybody
yeah it's awesome so athletes use it
lifetimes i know a lot of really
high-functioning people that do it it's
essential nutrition athletic screens
athletic greens it's going to give you
immune supporting
um not only if you get it but you'll get
one year supply of vitamin d one year
yeah
yes and five free travel packets so
athleticgreens.com
get them now hey dude
what's up are you into being focused oh
all the time you into sleeping well
100 okay how about how about digestive
health you want you want to be able to
yeah yeah you want to like get the
bubble guts and just
you want a strong stomach and then you
want your essential nutrients right yeah
like like say you want some extra energy
when you're skateboarding give me all of
it punk rocking
yeah if i'm on stage and i'm like yeah
yeah you might want some shroom tech
from yeah yeah yeah shroom tech from on
it you might want the best protein
powder sweetened with monk fruit because
they got scientists out there doing this
stuff i'm about that bone fruit you
should be yeah you got virotec virustech
immune instant that's a shroomtech
immune these are actual
actual immune agents that will stop a
cold in its tracks many times not always
but many times and i can say that
personally from my personal experience
so at the end of the day if you want to
optimize your body with great nutrition
if you want to optimize your body with
unbelievable fitness and you want to
start a home gym with kettlebells with
clubs with masons if you want an
on-demand workout at home
like a workout like decompress to defy
mobilize strength my warm-up your
workout kettlebell athlete morning
mobility move and groove these are all
30-minute workouts some of the best i've
ever had in my on my life
um i got a couple of their kettlebells
there you go and plus they got the
hydrocore bags the onnit sandbags the
battle ropes it goes on and on on it.com
fighter
optimize it's easy i got a question for
you so did you did you wear the sandals
today because brendan isn't coming no
because of my plantar fasciitis but it's
it's i think it's 100 no because there's
times where he's called you out on your
sandals and you you've changed your
shoes well first of all i should be
wearing my toehold
flip-flops
oh the only
i'll get everybody something no you
won't oh you won't wear them no no why
would i wear a [ __ ] toehold right you
never catch me some open-toed [ __ ]
sandals all right well as a black man in
america good for you uh all set good
fear all said i'm all
it's like the masculinity thing what if
they were alligator if they were
alligator get the [ __ ] out of here i'm
not my dad would he rock that all right
wait what is this what is this uh
this isn't all this is a different
company what is it oh total company yeah
yeah oh i thought it made that look like
really amazing i thought it was the uh
high quality flip the [ __ ] flip-flops
where you put your feet in no they do
toe makes like
saltwater crocodile flip-flops they make
alligator flip-flops they make [ __ ]
everything they got an african leathers
you don't get like massage to help that
[ __ ] out or something
i don't want to go into it but it's a
long story about plantar fasciitis but
i'm 100 better i think you're 100
percent better yeah pretty much
you do you are yeah all right i'll trust
you when your shoes constrict sometimes
your toes like this
it cuts off the blood to your heel so
like if you jump in the future in my ear
if you jump in here your foot get [ __ ]
up
you just do a simple jump not right now
no like but like
that's how bad that [ __ ] is it was i'd
wake up and i was like i can't walk
well i'm glad you're good now oh yeah
yeah i mean your feet are your feet are
getting better your teeth are getting
better
you're just doing it i got this i got
two more months of this [ __ ] two more
months yeah it's dumb
and [ __ ] invisible
it is really funny man i want news but
listen there are so one of my boys i
don't want to say his name because i
want to out him because he [ __ ]
he might be be embarrassed but he's
going to sweden
and he's doing it for like three grand
no i know the best hair guy on the
planet it's not that i do
it's not that i still would have to get
the hair taken from back here and put in
here it's fine and that's the way they
do it i know i just
again it's like
it takes a long time so how do you want
something but don't want to go through
the [ __ ] process of doing i want them
to clone hair you want them to what i
want them to be able to clone [ __ ]
hair i'm
like make make my hair grow hair i want
to grow my own you want them to put
something on you to wear your hair yeah
yeah i do like a [ __ ] like a like a
garden
yeah you want a garden
you want to [ __ ] guard it plant the
seeds that's what you want you want to
come in with seeds and [ __ ] i don't know
if they have that well you know they
have to they have to use your hair hair
no i got it back your hair now i gots to
wait
because when i did this [ __ ] i was 40.
but also
what's wrong with this look younger than
40. what's wrong with this nothing i'm
i'm cute
well there's nothing i don't know here's
the thing about getting over chapelle
all right
drop 55. let me explain to you i'm 35.
yeah now for 35 is good
35 hell you could look amazing you look
better at 40. you could look better
right you could you could every day from
here on out you could be getting
stronger in better shape yeah more
flexible okay there comes a point in
your life at a certain age
it's like the red queen problem in alice
in wonderland you got to run as fast as
you can just to stay in the same place
yeah
when you get to a certain age every
single [ __ ] minute
minute that passes you ready for this
every minute
every day every year
no matter what you do
no matter what drugs you're on
no matter what you do every single
minute you get
a little uglier and a little weaker
hey i said it i mean if you were
beautiful i don't know that's a oh wait
a minute hold on that's this is where
[ __ ] real
steroids come in i think you and jamie
foxx are the same age look at him
yeah jimmy fox is special look at that
guy
you [ __ ] joking me how old is this oh
yeah it's all over 15. hold on
well that that guy's a doctor and he
does nothing but steroids and i don't
think he looks good look at all the
human growth look at how his stomach is
his nipples too his nipples are long
well he had kind of is that is that
really is that really that dude yeah he
had got a master i think and he had to
probably have it operated on
wait no no is that really that dude yeah
same guy the noses look this diff look
different lost a lot of weight too
though i mean you know you lose weight
in your nose i think so what wait go
good there's no [ __ ] way that's all
roids but it's all good like
it's all good 74 year old bodybuilding
wow that guy's incredible wasn't it that
guy hold on go back to the guy with the
[ __ ] bald head and the mustache that
guy was [ __ ] awesome wait baltimore
yeah that guy how old is that
[ __ ] over 50. you gotta love
that dude that works great he already
had a great body and he just kept you
know
doing it he doesn't even look like he's
that he doesn't even look like he's
doing that many
yeah he looks like just a good body yeah
yeah some of these guys get a little
crazy but
so you just you're satisfied with where
you're at
never
never said they wanted to try to look
like that
i'd have to get on the old juice and
then i have to do it the right way which
i will eventually you won't
i will i doubt you will right you know
brian
brian
there's no way in [ __ ] hell you're
just gonna start at 55. well it's not a
great look to me when somebody is really
old and they're that muscular i just
don't get it it's like all right well he
doesn't look bad
oh the uh this guy that's in the picture
right here
he doesn't look that old either though
yeah
i i think maybe see i have mixed with my
feeling is that some in some ways well
in some ways i kind of want to be the
kind of guy that
i just don't want to be afraid of death
and i feel like this is all [ __ ]
do you say these are guys that are
afraid of death yeah you're doing your
best not to get old no i think i think
they're just like hey let's [ __ ] why
not i only got a few more
decades left
that's what i think i mean you know i
just don't feel like i need it i got
energy but maybe
maybe i [ __ ] will get on the old the
old sauce i've been 50 50 year old women
bodybuilders let's see what they're
popping on look at that guy down there
wait go down where right right here go
down uh one go down right to there look
at that guy
how old is that dude you got a lot of
[ __ ] man after the age of 40 so i'm
not sure he's yeah he's definitely fast
forward
he's got he's got to be like late 50s
yes yeah or how about six yeah he's got
to be in the 60s yeah
that's impressive
and you start chapel you want women yeah
that's what they look like
oh man
this is tough
that's pretty cool
[Laughter]
wait go back to that lady right there
yeah i mean that's impressive what where
let me see more of what she's about look
at her face all right it might be
photoshopped
i like uh i find that you know wrong
with that no
you can do a lot you do a lot to
transform your body you can eat right
and do all that hey what's up mom
angela it's a lot of work she's good
asian
oh damn
all right so that is
that's an aggressive amount of [ __ ]
work
yeah what would you call that warrior
mentality she's 61.
she's 61 61.
that's him brian what's that would you
call that warrior mentality mentality no
no i would call that fear of death and
fear of mortality and i would call that
i would call that sort of um
you know that's a it's your it's a form
of armor that you are
building because
in some ways
reality is a little bit too much to bear
for all of us
some people rage against the night we
all do it in our own way everybody
here's what everybody wants ready what's
everybody want what's everybody love
more than anything else
anything else
close
that's in the area what does everybody
want they love it more than their own
children in many ways
it's why they love their children you
can make the argument uh health
immortality
everyone wants to live forever
it's why your work is important if
you're an artist or you know it's why
your legacy is important it's why your
kids are important
you pass on your genes there's some
strange thing in us that
wants we have this ego that makes us go
i want to [ __ ]
you could call it ego you could call it
the will you call this this yeah you
could call this in this sort of will
this this drive is like that great thing
it's like we have a drive
to
stay alive and to
last and so
what that hat what happens there is
you you have to that's a full-time job
you have to eat
you have to make money to eat
you have to procreate you have to um
and then you have to have like shelter
you have to go to the bathroom you have
to sleep yeah but if you think about all
that it takes all the time it takes just
to stay alive
just to keep your body at the kind of
temperature
it needs to be
just to thrive right and then you know
where the you know when we forget we're
human when do we forget we're human
when do we forget that we're biological
machines that need to be fed and stuff
like that
think about a human
he literally asked us that like he's a
tv what are the moments we stay alive
for go ahead go ahead
oh i was like
when we connect when we fall in love
those moments right when you have deep
deep connection intimacy with somebody
you forget you have to go to the
bathroom you forget everything
but we also have those moments when we
are creating or witnessing great art
great music
great film
great painting or a great story you say
that's what we don't feel like because
you're wrapped you're enraptured you're
you're you're you're you are raptured
it's like you're
you're you ever have that where you
listen to a song and you can't you you
can't believe people don't believe in
god
you listen you're like how the [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying like yeah yeah yeah
yeah like damn it's just like a
song yeah and it's it hits you in a way
that kind of takes you out of
yeah out of like kind of an out of body
experience yes great film great film
that changes the way you look at life
where you come out of the film and you
go i gotta [ __ ] i gotta change i
gotta wake up
and you're just like yeah i need to
[ __ ] do something yeah
romance
adventure
drama
you know what's so funny when i was
younger i used to [ __ ] believe
in rom-coms so much and i thought that
was like
how
but that is
it's no it's not
but no because it's an ideal that you're
reaching for what so rom-coms do two
things what do they do they make you
laugh and cry
and then when they're not making you
laugh and cry they're really good
there's that in-between space and that i
call aw
uh-huh right that that that moment where
you where like you're laughing because
it's so funny and that's its own that's
its own hypnosis crying because it's so
beautiful or it's so sad or life is just
like that and it reminds you of
something that you know deep sorrow but
that deep sorrow is so [ __ ] moving
right yeah and then there's that
in-between thing which is
like this this this feeling like if
there is a god it must look something
like that
like when you're when when somebody wins
against all odds and it's a feeling of
glory and you just start crying because
it's too much for you to handle
for me i guess what rom cause what it
did for me it didn't let me be realistic
about it but you shouldn't be sometimes
who the [ __ ] wants to be realistic and
when it comes to like love and [ __ ]
[ __ ] it
what do you mean [ __ ] it you don't stay
alive for being real you stay alive for
the ideal you stay alive so you can so
you can be
um taken away somewhere
i guess i'm talking to like
13 year old chappelle
where i would just ask out a [ __ ]
girl on a heartbeat yeah there was
there'd be no build up no talk no
[ __ ] i was like hey you want to be my
girlfriend well 13 year old chapelle
might know something that 35 year old
should have forgot
what is that brian i don't know that
that the belief in what is it what is
that what are you saying just shoot your
shot
believe it or not believe in true love
optimism
the truth of how you feel and following
through with it i don't [ __ ] know
what do you got jim
is this too much how's this podcast been
it's good it's a good conversation it's
a good cover backstory too what'd you
say good backstory on both of you
comedy all that good stuff i gotta get
on a plane at 4 45. there you go oh yeah
yeah
it's all good yeah what do we got out of
town yeah all right first thing we got
to blast this out real quick uh we have
a show called cats after dark with
chappelle cat myself meatball and nick
love it that's on the thick bowl youtube
channel so if you guys want to check it
out um it's a lot of fun also brian if
you ever want to come on you're yes
please cry oh come on jonah that'd be
sick
just literally just walk over there
after the show
all right
all right the first one is chris rock's
first um i guess the first time he said
anything about the whole the will smith
slap and it was at a show all sold out
too someone caught a [ __ ] video of it
yeah these [ __ ] i know they love it
but at least they didn't keep them they
were common for him he almost started
crying really yeah yeah i guess was a
five minute standing ovation
he
how was your weekend
had like a whole show i wrote before
this
weekend
and i'm still kind of processing
what happened
[Applause]
no
uh new video says david pink and still
smith laughing after will
slap chris rock yeah yeah there was a
rap report posted damn there was another
angle where
he just talked to rap by the way yeah
all right right here
i think people thought it was a joke
wow dude
it was a g.i
my wife's name
i'm glad
[Music]
wow she should have kept that same
energy during the joke that was that's
[ __ ]
every time every time i see that [ __ ]
clip i don't like it i don't like it
it's just [ __ ] comfortable it's so
trash like these [ __ ]
it is also like it's also like um
yeah anyway i get but also listen i know
that level of like anger
i get that because i've set off
you know pre-pre-anger management chapel
not within recent okay not within recent
yeah pre-anger management was like set
off like just emotionally like that
that's all it was yeah like all of us
just reacting off of emotion and not
[ __ ] you know so i i do get the fact
of like getting to this point to where
you've boiled up so much
and then [ __ ] you know you just
[ __ ] react but
i mean i don't know i just think the
whole situation is [ __ ] christian
it's just
christmas chris rock should've been like
okay
i'm going to
jada
[Laughter]
jade
i got it i got this great jade
hey is jay
z
did you see that video where he talked
about like being
bullied or picked on there's some who
which one uh chris rock
he talked about he talked about like
being bullied and picked on when he was
like younger which is like obviously i
think inspired so uh everybody hates
chris everybody he's chris like you know
it just
kind of made the funny of it and took
the power of it but it was an
interesting uh clip i wish i knew
well the whole thing was very strange i
think it was something with dl
hughley that did yeah it was strange
yeah
but
all right what else there's an update on
that kid that drove through the tornado
oh yeah yeah they gave him a brand new
chevy this is the dealership
chevy silverado good like
like maxed out too that's great and they
did they donated fifteen thousand
dollars to him as well damn really yeah
because he had i guess he has a back
fracture he has a wife yeah oh [ __ ] he
has a what a back fracture
yeah oh [ __ ] and then also there's a
gofundme that is because the school did
and that's already past three they're
thirty thousand dollar bills and dude
the best thing that happened to him yeah
a lot of people don't have that level of
[ __ ] work ethic these days
i'm impressed he's the hope for the new
generation kept going because he's what
he's in high school yeah he's 16 years
old think about that he looks like he
looks every bit of 40 but he looks a
little older
he looks a little old that's the oldest
16 year old i've ever seen in my [ __ ]
life
you know what your kids come through you
some kids are born to be artists now
there's warriors now there's to be 40.
it is funny what i thought it was kids
are born to look like a middle-aged man
and that's how it is
some kids at 16 are born to be artists
others are born to be a middle-aged man
with a bunch of kids and when i saw that
picture i was like damn his dad dressed
up
yeah that's a big kid right there
big boy
all right that's why he survived that
[ __ ]
so this asian american journalist who's
been with this uh abc affiliate called
como for i think over 20 years he was
fired because he he did a story about
the proud boys and he did a story about
he was fired
so
ship is alive and wait what i guess so
he was doing a twitter time kind of live
tweeting that's the best thing that
could have happened yesterday the daily
wire is going to pick him up right now
you know what this makes me think about
um let me see then go back let me read
this can you read out that
yeah go ahead and read it joe a reporter
for 20 years created a photo montage
with sound from march to from the march
to end his day and eclipse included
music from the rally that included a
song called we'll have our home again
although cho is unfamiliar with the tune
it is allegedly played frequently at
pride boy rallies and similar gatherings
i wanted to simply capture a moment in
time with authentic visuals and sounds
it was clearly misinterpreted by some
online because of the uproar khloe said
his news director told him to take down
all his social media related to the
proud boys rally he did so but was fired
the following day
i've been a journalist now for more than
20 years that there was a ku klux klan
rally and cross burning at seattle
center in downtown i would be the first
person there to cover the event my job
is to present all sides not just the one
that aligns with my values or world view
joe added that he has covered antifa
violence and destruction in the city as
well my problem arises when any group or
side tries to silence me for simply
trying to show what's happening at the
end of the day all i can do is shine a
light on issues that matter to the
community fairly and accurately hey
daily wire pick him up that's a great
journalist and and i love when when
wokeville does dumb [ __ ] like this it
just it just shows you how [ __ ]
stupid they are right have you you've
heard of daryl davis right no the black
gentleman yes
he's amazing he's one of my heroes like
think about that like i love his [ __ ]
story and what he's done yeah he's
incredible and all he did
like as a black man yeah he goes
and goes through these
and all he says is like i'm just trying
to get to know what you guys do i love
it he's and like he learns all this [ __ ]
and
and and documents it and he talks about
it he has a story to [ __ ] tell and
it's like that's the unique part and i
guess like over
200 some uh
gentlemen have left the kkk yeah because
but that's just based off him having a
conversation with him yeah and sometimes
he changes he changes minds and dumb
dumbs at this news station and they're
so [ __ ] dumb these morons who fired
cho this [ __ ] new this director and all
those all you [ __ ] sheep dum-dums
you're doing
zero
nothing to make the world more equal
you're doing zero to make the more world
more fairer equitable or less racist you
are the dumbest virtue signaling losers
you are you are liars and they are just
the worst people so the worst people
they're gonna be worse than than the kkk
are those [ __ ] that fire that
guy because they're cowards yes little
[ __ ] there's this guy okay hey guys
do you have a sense of how i feel
was that was that enough
like when i think about that daryl davis
situation and
you know
just through conversation
genuine conversation and just get just
asking
these clan members questions just asking
them questions
he let them talk
they were able to hear them hear
themselves and then they go
what the [ __ ] am i doing yeah you know
what i mean like that's
that's like the
that's that's progress yeah that's what
that is of course it is it makes you
feel like an anger management when i
would hear the things i would say like
when they would ask me a question like
oh
oh so that's how you react to me you
know what like just basic
like just change the way you yeah they
didn't come at me with aggression
and and be like oh you know because
that's not how that works yeah but when
you just but what he did was all he did
was [ __ ] uh cover something and
they're like you're giving a voice to
the proud boys
and the their leader is an afro-cuban
guy by the way it's hilarious anyway i
like he said afros i can't deal with
these [ __ ] you're bringing afro
back they're so that you're they're so
they they are
the worst kind of people because they're
liars they're they're acting like
they're doing something that's actually
helping racism you know you're not
you're worse than the proud boys you
[ __ ] you hypocrites
all right this is a sad story sorry
pretty sad story so bruce willis had to
retire from acting yeah because he has
aphasia about this for a long time you
know okay he's got what he's asian he's
for a long time he doesn't he can't form
words and he can't really understand
what you're saying it's really awful
it's very very sad he's got a very bad
uh
it's it's a
it's a degenerative disease it's like
how do you even catch it dementia he
stopped being able to really talk or
understand lines i mean is it something
you're born with that just comes over
time
i heard that the last couple movies he
did he had to wear an earpiece and they
fed him the lines for that right that's
right
yeah and now he's gotten to a point
where it's very difficult he doesn't
know
how old does he know he's just uh 61 64.
i don't know it sucks man
667 yeah
yeah he's a good actor and a good guy
from what i hear so
all right um this i thought was very
interesting
this is according to
ukraine's security service
it's they're saying that some russian
soldiers were caught in audio
saying stuff about the soldiers in
ukraine the russian soldiers in ukraine
they're saying they're incompetent
and a bunch of other crap here you'll
see
wait some russian soldiers
don't know why they're there
these guys are young men who don't have
any idea why they're there they don't
want to be there it's so bad that
russians are getting killed too are we
going to slowly shift themselves there
are losses many wounded some russian
soldiers telling his wife
and then um
the whole army is stupid no one among us
is left they'll keep going until all of
us is killed he tells his mother the
whole army with us is stupid morons
yeah
it's such a it's so sad because they
yeah they don't want to be there yeah of
course ukrainians don't want to be there
fighting them yeah let him go home stop
this
[ __ ] dude yeah you almost like if you
know what i do i always like i i try to
find a
i just probably just try to find like a
like a parking lot and i'd be like hey
guys can i shack up with you guys
over again oh no i got i got captured by
some hot ukrainian girls it was terrible
they made me cook the whole time and i
had to cuddle
oops that's what you wanted yeah all
right yeah that's your culture
[Laughter]
like it just captured me dude send me
home yeah
and related to this so putin signed a
decree and listening he's gonna enlist
134 500 men from april to like july yeah
he's a real humanitarian
i mean you know he's [ __ ] so
stressful to [ __ ] listen zelinski's
willing to give them he's willing to
claim ukraine in neutral territory but
he's now he wants to [ __ ]
keep going i don't know
okay [ __ ] i didn't see this video but i
saw this
floating around
so this is a florida high school and so
let's just read about what happened here
first so witnesses say the runner in the
first place yelled at the athlete in
black to move but when he when the next
lap came around the guy appeared to
purposely get in the way of the of the
runner by standing on the track and then
the runner then pushed the athlete in
black to get him out of the way and then
that's when this thing happened oh
don't [ __ ] around
so you're just smacked in front behind
which is it i hate that again sucker
punching
the dad in the background are you
[ __ ] kidding me
let's keep going guys
wow what do you do at that point
they didn't catch video of the homie the
the the [ __ ] earlier that's it that's
losing your [ __ ] yeah
yeah no idea
not good
well
yeah
there it is kids is there one the last
one here
in april there's going to be an option
to write i've been transgender on a
passport yeah wait what
yeah right under the gender binary or
just x so it's not just male or female
on your passport you could be good luck
trying to get into some countries for
that they're going to be like
we don't recognize this so oh yeah some
cr some countries are [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah like israel and [ __ ] like they
won't well they just lie look at it or
just be like all right whatever it's
like you know
i don't think interpol is going to [ __ ]
with that but so brendan
uh
shall be friends april 6th
uh
at the hollywood improv um i think
you'll be on it we'll be on it whatever
doing the damn thing then he's in
phoenix april 14th through the 16th at
stand-up live and then he's at moon
tower comedy festival april 22nd in 20
uh through the 23rd
and then uh he's in philly
may 19th through the 21st at uh helium
comedy club and then the other helium
that's good oh is that good that's good
oh
i'm going to show you this
i'll be in temp april
15 and 16th that's a friday saturday two
shows friday two shows saturday get your
tickets at briancallen.comcasey.com
fatkc.com thanks for stopping by
tampa florida then port charlotte
florida at the bassani comedy theater
april 21 23rd that's the next weekend
i'm in florida again then las vegas
nevada wise guys comedy club april 28 to
30. april i'm i'm in
vegas and i'm in florida let's go all
right april 8th and april 9th i'll be in
salt lake city which is next weekend get
your damn tickets salt lake city wise
guys comedy club i love that damn club
uh may 6th through 7th new comedy club
in san diego called mic drop comedy club
uh and then i'm i'll be doing a one
nighter in the hometown may 12th at
phoenix stand up live
thank you
all right sign off let's sign off all
right kids this is the batter and the
kid
this is matter and chappelle and there's
the kitten chapelle
we're kidding the cheerleader yeah kids
god bless